[Musica]
per tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
e oggi siamo nel primissimo episodio di
harry wales ragazzi ci ho messo un
secolo per riuscire a farlo me lo avete
chiesto e me lo state chiedendo ancora
happy with me l'avete chiesto proprio
quando da quando aperto il canale
praticamente di farlo non l'ho mai fatto
perché secondo me lo facevano in troppi
però comunque continuato a chiedermi
adesso che alla fine
ognuno ha il suo modo di dire di
commentare un videogame quindi e niente
per questo weekend di accompagno con
happy with e deve essere il primo
episodio non avendo mai provato a
registrare nulla su happy ways
non so che cosa può uscire fuori allora
facciamo innanzitutto soft by rating
così almeno escono i livelli più votati
di questa settimana quindi ragazzi in
zona idea di che cosa sto per andare a
giocare comunque raga troviamo il
livello prima che io faccio
un'interruzione che duri troppo andiamo
su rock swing il primo che è capitato e
mi ispira press z vai mi deve aggrappare
ok
sono partito malissimo raga dovevo
aggrapparmi ok rifaccio di facili faccio
ci mette un po però alla fine capisco
poi prendi o se bene lascio lascia lo
lascio ok ok mi si è spezzato una gamba
non importa noi possiamo fare senza
gambe senza gamberaia senza gas
ok anche senza braccia senza niente mi
sto mi stanno usando il piede perché
come inizio è stato pessimo ragazzi devo
riprovare perfetto che atleta che ha ma
neanche al circo vedete ste cose
ok devo riuscire a staccare tagliati una
gamba tagliate la staccati brutto
stronzo
ok va bene dai ancora una spinta ancora
una ancora una ok ok se mamma mia
peggio di solid snake ragazzi peggio di
solid snake ok di nuovo la gamba andata
non importa senza gambe
vai così ok ok se la gamba ragazzi
sbilancia tutto bene bene bene bene bene
bene ci siamo siamo atleti
siamo troppo forti ok siamo partiti
mazzo che serpentone non solo che stiamo
andando la cava non importa c'è una
gamba che penzola
cos'è cos'è cos'è
ok ok ok mamma mia mamma mia secondo
tentativo raga la gamba ed io siamo ci
siamo salvati
andiamo sul prossimo livello perché ce
ne sono veramente tantissimi tra l'altro
se avete dei livelli belli io non so
come come andare avanti in questa sera
io penso di fare sempre livelli che che
sono stati portati in modo alto diciamo
però odio chi è questo ammazzo quasi ci
riprovo vai ok no ho preso ho preso
l'altro perché perché ho preso l'altro
ci riprova ragazza o quattro spade
insieme mamma appeso tipo appendiabiti
ragazzi non ci arriva il coltello sono
cadendo tutti stanno cadendo tutti che
tu non puoi passare ti esorcizzo
funziona
cos'è questo cosa sta arrivando oddio no
non posso difendermi non va ok bene mia
mi ha schiacciato perfetto ok e non fate
domande passiamo al prossimo livello
perché questa completamente nonsense
basketball basketball mi ispira ad oggi
io no fantastico questo devo riprovarci
ragazzi ci riprova la mamma mia mamma
mia kobe bryant canestro con le gambe
devo prendere la gamba presumo è la la
palla sia la gamba però è impossibile
tuffa bomba mamma mia mamma mia mamma o
chi ha questo ai fan
se è così e ragga così no mi avete
lasciato indietro la limousine e mia a
star di ok
devo riuscire a far canestro cadevo
riuscirci assolutamente perché se no si
spera solo che io ci sia riuscito però
la boe le braccia in compenso mi si sono
spezzate proseguiamo raga orange and
free for drug
e di che cosa sia di svariare depresse z
to begin the madness
io sono più potente riesco a fare tutto
ok
la gamba raga e nostra amica perché si
stacca sempre all'inizio si vede che non
ha fiducia in noi però ok anche tutto il
resto del corpo non ha fiducia in noi ma
noi proseguiamo ce la faremo senza cuore
ok
ok ci riprovo e mi è saltato tutto ok
possiamo fare così all'inizio di ogni
livello però staccati di ota perfetto ok
la gamba stavolta niente non faccio in
tempo a dire che la gamba non si è
staccata che si stacca subito ma non
importa proseguiamo vai staccati che noi
siamo più non ci facciamo infilzare da
delle robe stupida vai così senza casco
senza testa senza senza niente per dire
ok è un flipper umano ragazze va beh no
no la testa la testa batterò la testa se
gioca no ok sono i vantaggi sono i
vantaggi sono i vantaggi sono in
vantaggio
no mi ha superato bastarda no no no te
cos'è questo braccio no no no no la
testa mi ha battuto
mi ha battuto la testa stronza niente la
testa è più forte era più allenata non
fa niente
ok raga andiamo su hi there you to win
li sto scegliendo completamente a caso
perché non ne ho idea di nuovo ma tutte
ste partenze cioè non ha senso
mai così vai se ok la sedia la terra
buono
lo scopo di harry potter
[Musica]
ragazzi il prossimo il prossimo episodio
qui dice impossible jump in prossimo per
me ma stiamo scherzando vai con obesa
raga non esiste la parola impossibile
per me non esiste gode chi o che cosa
dovrei fare qui devo devo andare di
sorgia non riesco a salire sto pezzo
figuriamoci tutto il resto
ok forse è meglio che cambi personaggio
e scelga il nostro cerchio preferito non
pensi c'è larga lui è il mio preferito
vi annuncio non ci devo trovare ancora i
nomi a tutti quanti tranne atti micheli
che mi sta incitando ma lui questo qui è
in assoluto il mio preferito vai
ok la testa mi stava già partendo ma va
bene così vai così no ok che è successo
e timothy mi sta incitando dove vai
timothy devices paventato cosa sta
facendo la mamma sta controllando se hai
fatto la papa te la fai ancora addosso
bene tornano fatte con comodo io torno a
fare quello che stavo facendo sotto il
tavolo ripara donna
sappi che mi hai deluso team mi hai
deluso tantissimo te la fai ha ancora
addosso
ok scusami temi ma devo riuscire a
passare perfetto
ok ok non sono posizioni oscene solo
tentando di uscire da qui perfetto
scusami non so come uscite timothy non
hai visto niente
se azzardi a raccontare la polizia
quello che è successo farai la stessa su
identica fine bari ha già abbiamo fatto
bene ragazzi riprovo
niente impossibile sappiatelo per me
niente è impossibile ci prova dai così
fai così 9 9 9 9 99 in pose facciamo
tutti gli impossible raga tanto per me
niente è impossibile non ha senso
ok a parte questo no no no mi stava
prendendo bene
macché goal of the dead prez pesaro stu
movc il all ok ok
beh se agopuntura laica boss o infilzato
tutto tranne il melone tra l'altro vai
così bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
fantastico sono un killer nato raga
prossimo one chance mi mi attira ragazzi
con chance to kill the backs ok dai
beach e porta via da si è preso proprio
dritto tipo beh secondo me faceva più
male così che prendono con la lama bene
perfetti i gettoni mi piacciono mi
attirano non so perché vai vai così
perfetto gettone ok no mamma mia mamma
mia che schivata che è schivata vai
ok perfetto ok ok perfetto cos'è sta
roba
un pistone devo attivare quella leva non
chiedetemi perché raga non ho più
pallida idea è un po un casino quando ci
sono sì livelli tipo platform semi flat
forno o sfasciato qualcosa hanno aperto
la porta perfetto ok non ti lascia
schiacciare da quei cosi benissimo
benissimo
no no no che schifo ma che schifo
qualche violenza è mi ricorda tanto come
si mangia il riso alla giapponese con i
bastoncini per ora proviamo a no non lo
rifaccia non c'ho voglia passo
direttamente al prossimo bello di
trovarne uno che sia abbastanza decente
diciamo
bis slide in family mimì mi attira
diciamo andiamo con babbo natale
ok ok se babbo palla da bowling primo no
ultimo terzo team ibizia [ __ ] team i
battiti lo sapevo che ti caga vi ancora
addosso è colpa dei bambini che portano
ancora il pannolino rock swing space non
so che cos'è raga faccio un ultimo
livello di oggi fatemi sapere con quali
sono i livelli che vi piacciono di più
così almeno farò mi concederò di più su
quelli dato che questo è il primo
episodio state siate buoni perché non so
come va era un po un esperimento ok sta
sta partendo il razzo ma sono partito
soltanto io non chiedetemi perché swing
to site safety perfetto sono un partito
malissimo vai occhi
[Musica]
missione compiuta ok ok ok ok se è preso
fai così vai così tarzan 2 la vendetta
oddio mi sono preso un bar o chiedo
riuscire a cambiare mai così si mamma
mia mamma mia mamma mia
cos'è missione su marte raga mai stata
così strana però torniamo sulla terra io
son perfetto
cos'è no no la testa la testa va bene
ragazze la testa infilzata visto
adottiamo fatemi sapere comunque quali
sono gli episodi quali sono i livelli
che vi piacciono di più così nei
prossimi episodi come è successo è
partita la testa non facciamoci domande
tanto ai più questo è strano così
accendo la luce perché si vede poco
a fine episodio giustamente perché sono
un genio niente fatemi sapere se vi
piace innanzitutto e se vi piace quali
sono i vostri livelli che preferite che
io faccia così almeno nei prossimi
episodi sarà sarà meglio tra l'altro è
tornata sono tornate le dame senza la
testa non chiedetemi dov'è finita e dai
se vi è piaciuto il video
lasciatemi piace anche la pagina
facebook che trovate in descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi ci
vedevano un prossimo video bella ragazzi